bonjour a tous invités donc de sao qu'a
dit ce matin meygal aventure membres du
conseil exécutif de la 7e bonjour
bonjour à vous et bonjour à tous nos
auditeurs de marthe les premières vous
avez en charge les finances de la
collectivité la semaine dernière vous
avez présenté les orientations
budgétaires et ce qui a bien retenu
l'attention
ce sont les augmentations des taxes
notamment les textes sur les carburants
vous toucher directement portrait des
martiniquais j'espère que ça que les
martiniquais ont retenu c'est évidemment
le dynamisme de cette collectivité
vous savez aujourd'hui il y a une
véritable nécessité de faire en sorte
que on aille mieux j'écoutais votre
édition tout à l'heure sur la
problématique du chômage
c'est ça la problème demeure l'une des
martiniquais il faut par conséquent
créer des jeux dirait il aura manqué le
coche 900 euros et qu'on lui rend
fonctionne encore mais qu'en plus on
touche à leur porte monnaie si vous
m'autorisez a évoqué les orientations
budgétaires peuvent vous proposer de
regarder je veux vraiment souligner cet
objectif de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
plus d'activités pour cela il faut par
conséquent aider les initiatives quand
vous avez j'imagine que vous en
connaissiez peut-être dans votre
environnement des personnes qui veulent
faire en sorte que les choses aillent
mieux
il faut pouvoir leur donner
l'accompagnement nécessaire ça nécessite
de la ressource
dans le même temps cette ressource eh
bien elles diminuent en ce qui concerne
les dotations de l'état
10 - 10 millions pardon c'est moins 10
millions c'est sain a beaucoup plus que
ça alors il ya moins 10 millions sous la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
mecelec le respect il ya également de la
diminution sur d'autres aspects et par
conséquent c'est la globalité de cet
appauvrissement de la ressource qui
est mise à la disposition qu'il faut
prendre en considération et dans le même
temps il y à la nécessité de faire en
sorte que nous puissions raccompagné
ceux qui sont aussi dans des situations
de 2,2 je dirais d'impératifs de
solidarité dans votre journal à l'instar
vous avez évoqué ces deux journées est
essentielle pour nous deux pour faire en
sorte que les personnes qui sont en
situation de pauvreté ou en tout cas
d'insuffisance de ressources puissent
avoir les accompagnements nécessaires
sélassié t aime bien voir l'initiative
et il va le faire avec la ressource
qu'elle peut mobiliser et bien parmi les
ressources qui peuvent être mobilisés il
y a effectivement ça que aujourd'hui
concrètement on peut mettre en oeuvre à
travers le fonds social européen c'est
ça le fond social européen et vous voyez
le dynamisme que nous mobilisons et par
conséquent donc l'idée n'est pas
simplement d'aller se mobiliser sur un
aspect mais oui il faut aller partout
chercher la ressource et il y a laroche
fiscal alors en particulier qui
effectivement a été envisagée mais avait
pas d'autre solution que de ponctionner
encore une fois les martiniquais
quand on sait que que que voilà on
connaît la pression fiscale on connaît
la situation difficile qui économique et
sociale et pas d'autres moyens
je viens de vous dire encore une fois je
vous remercie de l'avoir noter dans
votre propre journal il ya quelques
minutes nous allons mobiliser d'autres
ressources notamment des fonds européens
nous allons mobiliser avec une énergie
supplémentaire ce qui est susceptible
d'être mise en oeuvre au niveau national
il faut dire clairement que nous sommes
dans des débats compliqués avec l'état
qui aujourd'hui et dans des positions de
retrait par rapport à ce qu'il faut
faire mais il ya une solidarité
martiniquaise direct qui peut
s'organiser et de quoi parlons nous
disons les choses clairement il s'agit
de la taxe sur les carburants pour
laquelle il est proposé de se mettre au
niveau de la guadeloupe vous savez je
dis pas qu'il faut se comparer
systématiquement avec la guadeloupe
m'enfin quand on veut bouger et bien de
temps en temps il faut prendre quelques
repères
et quand on regarde que aujourd'hui en
guadeloupe et bien le super sans plomb
est un peu plus cher le gazole est
franchement plus cher
il ya les guadeloupéens aujourd'hui il
utilise donc cela un carburant qui vient
de la martinique et par conséquent donc
clairement aujourd'hui on comprend que
on doit pouvoir faire un petit effort
combien quelques centimes quelques
centimes 2 ou 3 centimes
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit cautionne dans
le super sans plomb concernant le gazole
ici un peu plus aujourd'hui le super et
le gazole est vendu 10 centimes plus
cher en guadeloupe qu'en martinique
aujourd'hui nous disons que est bien
avec la taxe sur les carburants
et puis un peu d'octroi de mer il est
possible d'avoir une ressource premier
d'argent c'est environ 8 millions
d'euros pour la ctm
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en
faisant cet effort qu'on demande aux
martiniquais dit aux martiniquais
il y a cinq millions 5 millions vous
entendez bien qu'ils sont destinés aux
communes et par conséquent c'est tout le
monde qui va souffrir mais c'est
également tout le monde qui va en
profiter
et quand vous dites qu'on ponctionne eh
bien nous on le fait d'une manière
complètement je dirais pas seulement
transparente mais répartie tandis que
vous le savez et bien prenez les budgets
de certaines communes qui aujourd'hui
hurle je veux pas prendre le cas
seulement de fort de france mais c'est
quand même un cas qui mérite d'être
regardée et bien vous avez des niveaux
de fiscalité qui font que et bien on est
malheureusement sur des hits parades par
rapport à tout ce qui se passe au niveau
national qui sont pas très glorieux dans
l'espace dans l'espace sud également
d'augmenter ces taxes foncières jeu je
ne veux pas pointer du doigt qui que ce
soit je n'avais pas une autre solution
pensent que par exemple je me suis dit
qu il n que plusieurs dizaines d'années
alors il nous semble que c'etait camille
darsières même j'en suis pas sûr qu'ils
avaient parlé de la taxe sur les jeux de
ponctionner à toute attaque sur les yeux
parce qu'on sait très bien que les
martiniquais sont de grands joueurs et
que la française des jeux hamas pactole
intéressant écoutez je vois merci
d'avoir souligné que c'est qu'il aurait
pu le faire
l'ont pas fait parce que je vous je vous
remercie c'est trop fine pourquoi pas au
danger nous est chose facile
aujourd'hui nous mettre en place écoutez
nous sommes là depuis on mettre cette
taxe en place nous sommes là les deux
solistes réfléchissons à toutes les
solutions
les fonds européens étaient pas
consommer nous leur donnons le dynamisme
nécessaire et nous les fléchon vers les
personnes qui ont le plus besoin
la pauvreté nous les organisons pour
faire en sorte que ceux qui ont des
idées et qui ont des projets puisse les
mettre en oeuvre
en créant des emplois jusqu'à présent
nous essayons de créer cette dynamique
là aujourd'hui on est à + 12 % de
consommation des fonds européens
alors que nos artistes nous ce que nous
sommes arrivés on était à 1 à 2%
voilà le progrès que nous avons faits
nous avons aujourd'hui à réfléchir à
faire en sorte qu'on puisse passer un
cap
quel est le budget 2010 est qui a besoin
d'une ressource pour les martiniquaises
et des martiniquais puisse avoir les
moyens de prospérer dans votre journal
ce matin encore moi j'ai entendu les
pompiers du sdiss expliqué que porter
secours aux martelly 15 et aux
martiniquais est compliqué parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens
ils ont reconnu que des efforts sont
faits depuis janvier de cette année eh
bien il faut qu'il faut continuer pour
ça il faut quelques moyens ce que nous
disons martinique et zions martiniquais
ça n'est jamais agréable ça n'est jamais
de gaieté de coeur qu'on augmente une
taxe ça n'est jamais un moment de
plaisir mais nous disons que c'est un
acte de responsabilité
et quand on entend ce qui se dit au
niveau des pompiers quand on quand on
mesure à quel point il ya un certain
nombre de chemins qui veulent créer des
activités et qui demandent par
conséquent d'être assistés et d
accompagner quand on voit à quel point
des personnes qui sont dans la pauvreté
ont besoin de l'accompagnement ne serait
ce qu'en termes j'veux dire hey de
pouvoir disposer des aidants vous savez
ces dispositifs
eh bien nous disons à chaque
martiniquais via chaque martiniquais oui
ça n'est pas joyeux ça n'est pas un
point de son pied que d'aller payer 2
centimes de plus ou 5 centimes de plus
mais nous disons que ça fait partie des
sacs de responsable adoptée et nous
assumons cette manière un peu solidaires
d'eux des grands chantiers de ce grand
chantier dans le tendon
dans ses orientations budgétaires pour
désengorger le nord le viaduc
vous réfléchissez à la construction d'un
viaduc sur fond l'aï c'est ça alors nous
avons effectivement quelques grandes
orientations qui sont en particulier
routière dans le domaine routier a
effectivement plusieurs grands chantiers
et à cette question de faire en sorte
que le no caraïbes ne soit pas en
permanence dans ce goulot d'étranglement
de fond là il faut il faut il faut
arriver à franchir cet espace l'idée de
viaducs et enfin retenu vous savez que
notre formation politique le propose
depuis des années mais n'a jamais été
vraiment plus au sérieux et et il y a
également 7,7 chuté chez expekt qui
normalement devrait enfin pouvoir
circuler
vous allez mener des études parce qu'il
y avait des études existent déjà
il n'existe aujourd'hui aucune étude
opérationnelle qui permettent de lancer
le chantier du viaduc
aucune fête du jeu par luthi s'inspire
levier j'espère qu'il s'agit de le
prolonger
dans le nord d'israël existe déjà et
aujourd'hui n'ont pas suffisamment et et
et de le prolonger dans le sud vers le
sud en direction de rivière salée et et
et vers l'ouest en direction de trinité
il faut anticiper vous savez nous on
veut faire en sorte que les choses se
passent de manière très dynamique à
paris tap
il est très important si on veut que des
chantiers soient réalisés que les études
opérationnelles soit fait qu'aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas ces études elles n'ont
pas été réalisés avant elles ne sont pas
dans les cartons nous faisons le
reproche à personne
nous disons et ben maintenant que nous
sommes à faire engageons le engageant le
travail et c'est l'occasion pour moi de
revenir sur la question de la taxe sur
les carburants
il est très important de se souvenir que
cette taxe elle a été prévue par la loi
comme devant être affectés à des travaux
routiers ou à des équipements de
transport et par conséquent quand on
paye quelques centimes de plus à la
pompe
on sait que ça va permet d'améliorer la
situation sur la route mais on sait
aussi que ça va donner du travail à des
martiniquaises et des martiniquais parce
que des travaux routiers
c'est des entreprises qui bosse j'ai des
ouvriers ils ont réuni gueule à mon
futur je vous remercie ça aux cadis
terminée mais
si beaucoup merci de votre habitation